el opositor cubano yunior garcía está en
españa- así lo confirmaron fuentes del
gobierno español este miércoles el
dramaturgo y miembro del movimiento
archipiélago principal convocante de las
frustradas marchas del pasado 15 de
noviembre él llegó esta noche entre el
martes y miércoles al aeropuerto de
madrid-barajas con su esposa -ambos con
un simple visado de turista de momento
se desconoce si siguen en la capital
española fuentes diplomáticas nos dicen
que de momento no han pedido asilo
político y las mismas fuentes citadas
por el diario 'el país' afirman que pues
las autoridades cubanas dejaron salir al
disidente si no no hubiera podido el
llegar a españa y afirman que no hubo
acuerdo entre la habana y madrid para
facilitar la salida del opositor
cercanos a junio- garcía confirma que
pues esta marcha está obviamente
motivada por las presiones policiales
recibidas estas últimas
semanas pero habrá que esperar a que el
opositor cubano salga de su silencio y
explique sus motivos y sobre todo
explique cómo se plantea su futuro
político